Negibus Kill that man
Can there be at least one way to stop this guy
?
My friends told me that it's impossible
[music] Stop everyone's words [music]
Let's believe in your own power
[music]
Hurry up and do that guy What did you do to the
behemoth
[music]
Tame this guy
I've put it under my control I've
overwritten the control of Moth that you have Ooh
,
overriding control
Originally, it
's impossible to take control of other subjects
But
the power that everyone says is mine
I thought it might be
possible I've never heard of taking control
[music]
I'm a good beast theme I'm the
one who tamed Behemoth 1
I'm the master
Don't provoke this guy, don't do it!
Fireball
Oh
, the hostility that demons have towards people
Even Tem can't completely erase it, it was
barely suppressed  But I
reacted to your hostility and went out of control for three years, but
there was no other way